the film you're gonna see tonight is
what is known as the version you've
never seen it
I added 12 minutes to the original
version of The Exorcist which came out
in 1973 there's a handful of shots but
basically the scenes were the second
psychiatrist scene and the scene between
Ellen and Max von Sydow where she asks
if he'd like some brandy in his tea
the final scene between Lee Jacob and
father bill O'Malley he was an actual
priest there were several other scenes
along the way and some shots and I took
them out after I showed the film to bill
bladdy and he loved the whole film but
then when I showed it to Warner Brothers
they made some suggestions and I thought
the suggestions were good and so I took
out 12 minutes for 25 years bill bladdy
would Hawk me every day about the 12
minutes that I took out of it and I used
to call him a sore winner
I'd say bill the film is a success leave
me alone
and one day he called me and I just
heard in his voice something and I loved
bill bloody he passed away last year and
I loved him and I wanted him to be
ultimately happy with the film so I
asked him to come out to California we
went to Warner Brothers and we looked at
the footage that I had cut and after I
saw it with Bill on a movie Ola I
remember putting my arm around him and I
said we'll bill I finally understand
what you were getting at and I added the
12 minutes back the studio wanted to
call it a director's cut but it's not a
director's cut this is the original
of the film that I showed to bill bladdy